one in ten Americans now uses ecig arete
s-- as part of their smoking habit one
in ten yeah
am i amazing people call it vaping and
unfortunately it has led to vape shops
that think they're being clever with
their store names I don't know if you've
seen these but they have clever names
now yeah like what was the one we were
talked about earlier what yeah but earth
vapor yeah yeah there was like there
they have like jokey vape names and I'm
afraid it's gonna get out of hand and in
fact I think it's already getting out of
it's out of hand like there's this one
this is real this is the vape goat I
don't know if you can see it right there
and there's a still and says go to still
yeah Oh incredible but timing on that
was beautiful
I think someone in the booth is vaping
right now no but you see what I'm saying
babe though you know that's like okay
really well guess what it's getting out
of hand I think it's just a matter of
time before we start to see things like
this planet of the vapes going vape [ __ ]
What's Eating Gilbert vape Sex Lies and
videotape I don't want to go in there
seven-foot vape worm that's just disgust
statutory vape and finally does the
carpet match the vapes
[Applause]
I think it's wrong hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy japanese pornography